[Applaudissements]
oui jean michel trouillet walo nager
j'ai lu dans un papier dernièrement vous
aviez un qi de 140 et donc je veux ça va
ce qu'amène vous pécho vous avez un mec
en ce moment oui j'ai quelqu'un depuis
trois ans mais elle est surtout les
dossiers amoureux en plus je sais qui et
je sais qui est le style donc là c'est
de ma faute al wahda vous pouvez dire
hanouna est un con ça nous dérange pas
de maintenant et oui non mais allégé les
revoilà
julien combes et vous n'avez que vous le
trouviez un peu sexy oui je trouve que
c'est l'animateur le plus sexy
il a accepté de faire qu'une seule télé
en direct depuis très longtemps
oui exactement et pourquoi tous pas mon
poste prochaine ce que je vous adore au
loana vous l'aimez bien bertrand
j'adore vous le regardez tous les soirs
il est trop beau elle et veut tout tout
aussi excusé talent non mais il a du
talent ce machin